[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by chad and jt
themselves who starring chad and jt go
deep which is on netflix now we'll be
talking spoilers about so make sure you
watch the show first and then come to
this interview how you guys doing today
good man good how are you
doing great uh so my first question is
for chad chad are you ready for the next
level of fame you guys are about to hit
now with this being on netflix
uh
dude yeah i mean i uh any sort of
opportunity to i think the goal is you
know we started local and we're trying
to go global so i think you know
being able to take our activism
to a global platform has always been the
goal because i think this
we want to change the world you know we
started with san clemente and now we
want to change the world and we want to
get want to get everyone so stoked so i
think if we can be
the stoke sort of figureheads in that
that fires me up
yeah hell yeah and i feel like it's it's
spreading fast now with it being on
netflix and the message is getting out
and
jt did you feel more pressure on this
project than anything you've ever done
because it's a speed exposure now going
global with netflix
um
yeah i think so but it it
it felt
easier i think than i would have
anticipated like it was a pretty
stress-free environment when we were
making it i think because
you know we had all our homies around us
so we had such a good
uh director and runner and dan lucasy
who's super talented and also just has
great vibes and and uh
you know from the top down like from him
[Music]
throughout the rest of the crew
it was just all uh
really cool people who made it easy to
work on and
and uh yeah i think i think going into
it i thought it would be more of
a a struggle than it turned out to be it
was actually a pretty smooth
um
experience so yeah just grateful for all
those folks
yeah so power of the squad i like that
now
chad was it what was it like getting to
hang with mia toretto herself jordana
brewster was that like a dream come true
for you oh the bucket list item yeah i
mean she's so iconic and like i remember
um when i first saw fast and furious i
was 11 with my dad my brothers you know
it was like being able to tell him like
we ran to
uh and at
uh neptune's net which is like where vin
and paul
have their uh fried shrimp so
it was um
i'm still buzzing off it to be honest i
mean she she's so sweet and awesome it
was just such a
uh she's so wise too and it was just
like uh
yeah it was a dream come true for sure
yeah and it's awesome that she seemed to
love you guys so that is an awesome
bucket list thing so
staying on that topic jt fast and the
furious 10 is coming out next year do
you and chad go opening night you guys
got any rituals for that when that comes
out
yeah we were trying to see each new fast
and furious in a different country
so uh
i think for this one we're going to
auburn jam
okay
that's that's awesome anything else you
would do for it or just you just trying
to
well yeah we i mean like there's a
we kind of do a
prayer slash meditation before each one
and after
you know kind of a spiritual cleansing
so that we're totally open and receptive
to the high art we're about to consume
and then afterwards we just in like the
theater lobby we hit our knees and we
hold hands and we just uh lay our heads
back almost in like
homage and in a like deference to the to
our great fortune that we get to exist
simultaneously with this you know
uh just
uh totem of of art and of squad love and
and you know hopefully we get the whole
crowd from the theater involved in that
as well because you know these hands we
got two hands so i'm holding chad's hand
and then this other hand is open so
let's let's link up
yeah and then just hearing that makes me
excited about the next fast fury so yeah
props to you guys it just got me back
into this franchise and
also with the show too
chad was there any city council meetings
or causes that didn't make the show that
you wish did that we didn't even see
um yeah let me think let's see
well we wanted to do something for labor
day you know um to commemorate the
people who don't want to work
um you know it's because it's like on
labor day you know you sort of are like
this is this is a celebration of labor
um which i think is a french term for
work
and so it's like but there's other
people we know you know sort of like our
buddy
um
[Music]
uh
our buddy [ __ ]
who
he just chills
and it's like just because he's not
working doesn't mean he's not a cool
dude and so we want another holiday to
be like
this is for the chillers you know this
is for [ __ ] who you know
um
just likes to
you know bake pies and and
you know
read philosophy
so
i think we would love to just sort of
commemorate those dudes
um yeah and shout out to him too dude if
you're listening you're a legend and i'm
looking for that pecan pie brother
yeah i would love that for
hopefully a season two that would be
great if you guys can explore that now
uh jt when i was wondering while
watching the show
seeing that strider does a lot of the
narration here is strider ever
approached you guys about getting his
name in the title of chad and jt go deep
like is there any
detention there
uh no but
i think
i think it's probably coming
yeah okay
yeah no no not detention but his name
in the title sorry i should clarify that
i think
i think
i think he's such a good dude you know
he'd be
he he's the funniest and the the
sweetest and chad often refers to him as
the glue
you know so
i think there's another project coming
up that
will be
strider based and that me and chad will
be just you know stoked to to assist on
or or
add some
some dressing too
yeah awesome he's like elmer's not wood
no he's like wood glue not elmer's sorry
a lot of purification this one we need a
lot of clarification yeah
no that's awesome and yeah he he was
definitely amazing in the show as well
and also just yeah what we're gonna say
yeah he's unbelievable he's so funny
yeah he's great and uh
it's interesting too with your guys
relationship
the show ended with you guys having
little bumpy moments here so
are you guys closer than ever still
currently are you guys all peace and
lovers that kind of go back and forth
with you two
i think we're definitely in a stronger
place for sure i mean you know i i think
i always had this sort of inner
voice in my subconscious just being like
you know jt is trying to shave your down
and uh
you know and it that that sort of is
those little things can like create
tension where it's like you know be like
hey let's go get in and out and i'd be
like
it's at the barbershop you know what i
mean and it's like it's totally
irrational but that's what i thought
and so for him to sort of push me to
sort of reach this new side of myself
where i faced my fears and um was able
to sort of let go of of these gnarly
attachments
that was huge and so now i'm like now
instead of being like what are you
trying to do here i'm like just like i'm
like thank you brother like you helped
me reach a new level of froth that i
didn't even know i could find
yeah like you know you got to go through
all the seasons with someone and i feel
like me and chad have been through like
you know all the
to quote ran all the seasons of love
together and and that's
that doesn't mean it's always like
stoke you know there's there's other
sides to things that
uh you know all the colors of the
rainbow like there's you know sadness
and and
and uh
and tension and and all these other
things and i don't know i think
it only makes the relationship fuller
but yeah we're stoked like we're just
having a good time all the time
except when we beef but then like
we d beef
and then it's
just straight stove yeah we throw it on
the traeger grill and just
you know
saute it yeah but yeah pull the grill
out and sometimes when we're beefing i'm
like do we need to pull the grill out
and then
we'll just sit there
and fake grill our beef and eat it
together and it's the length of a real
dinner we spend about two hours doing
that yeah
yeah i love that i think stoke nation is
gonna love to hear this update and
also i think we're all thinking now
about season two if it happens what i'm
thinking about being a new yorker myself
i couldn't just stop imagining you guys
being in times square doing what you do
would you consider coming to the east
coast branching out further here
oh absolutely i mean
you know from the big apple to the big
miami you know i definitely want to hit
the eastern seaboard and say what up to
the atlantic
you know it's like
just because we have more swell in the
pacific doesn't mean that the stoke is
not as high in the atlantic
and uh right you know i think uh
i think laird hamilton said that um and
so i do i love new york dude my
brother's out there
and so i'd do that you know hit up some
finance bros and just be like like are
you guys stoked you know even during a
recess
um so i think that that'd be huge
um
yeah i'd like like the atlantic's warmer
than the pacific which always trips me
up
yeah
for sure and i think that's like why you
guys should come and i think we we need
you guys here more than ever so that
would be awesome to see
um
chad what do you want people take away
most from this show after we've all
watched this
um
let's see
i think uh
i think the biggest thing is that
it's important to have a crew you know
it's it's important to
to to sort of
realize that relationships are there to
help you
uh blossom into your truest self you
know and to sort of face who you are and
your biggest fears and stuff and to sort
of
you know
just say gnaw to those fears and sort of
do an acid drop or no maybe just like
plow through the wall you know with a
250cc dirt bike you know crank a nos
energy drink and just you know crash
right through them and
and sort of express your fullest self
with full stoke so
yeah just you know love your bros and
your lady friends
i love that and yeah full stoke just
hearing that that's a whole philosophy i
gotta just think about that's great and
thanks
jt you know
what is the immediate next thing for you
guys what we're all going to be jonesing
now for what you do next where can we go
what's next for you guys and then what's
like the ultimate dream goals you guys
have planned like what's what's the
vision board here
um i think we're just going to stay busy
you know like
the show comes out but like our activism
hasn't stopped so
we're going to keep documenting that on
in as many different ways as we can and
i think
i think the ultimate goal is to
keep raising
the
[Music]
the stakes in terms of like what
environments were doing our activism you
know what i mean so like
you know i'll be totally candid and it's
like massively vulnerable but like
you know white house ambitions i think
you know we'd love to be like
secretary of defense
you know
in charge of transportation maybe even
you know
dip my tone to ag
meaning you know
great culture so that's that's kind of
the those are the ambition
wow i mean that's amazing and that that
gets me excited for what you guys can do
next uh
really just awesome stuff here
guy everybody check out jad and jt in
chad and jt go deep it's now on netflix
spread the word about it we got to get
everyone talking about this and check
out their podcast too chad and jt go
deep you can check it out on youtube
everybody listen to podcasts guys thank
you so much for joining me today and i
hope talking in the future yeah it was
nice to have you man yeah it's great to
have you
thank you